what people offer me every day for my
time is usually between 25 and 50 000 an
hour me writing a book takes like this
next book that's going to come out 100
million dollar leads it'll probably take
me by the time it's published about 1300
hours and I'm gonna give it away for 99
cents and so if I think about that like
okay well 25 000 times a thousand is 25
million so I put 25 million dollars of
what I probably could have spent time on
directly into this book that I'm gonna
give away for 99 cents if I'm using the
net worth stick it would be a failure
and I should do other stuff that I would
get a better return on my time on but in
terms of the Goodwill and the amount of
people that it will reach there are few
that are better and it will outlive me
YouTube videos will not outlive me book
will and so when I think about that long
term like that's when I'm on my deathbed
having nothing left to give I want to
extract everything I can out of my head